LISA: Here Zuli!
Zuli got Valley Fever, and she started coughing
four weeks after we moved here and got a fever,
and I took her in and x-rayed
her lungs and they looked just
like lungs of dogs who had Valley Fever.
We have a lot of rooms with rope poles
and we had a hundred tons of new soil,
native soil, brought into the yard.
So it was pretty clearly some kind of a point
exposure probably associated with something
that was going on in this
backyard when we moved in.
We can all get it from the same thing.
I mean, we can all breath the same spores.
So... but you can't get it from the
dog and the dog can't get it from you.
My mother's had it, she's immune.
ANN: I've had it.
I had it way back in the 70's and I had to have
surgery for it because we had no medication
and they removed part of the upper right
lobe of my lung and that was in 1970.
She brought her home and she
discovered the Valley Fever.
LISA: Took them months.
ANN: It was October, she was - LISA: 23rd.
ANN: October 23rd and she couldn't walk.
She couldn't continue.
Lisa had to pick her up and carry her home.
She wouldn't eat and Lisa fed her three
times a day by hand for nine months.
She tried every drug that was available
and it was not working and that's
when they went to the able center.
LISA: The company that developed the drug
gave us about $10,000 worth of medication
and we treated 23 really sick dogs over
the next two-and-a-half to three years,
and that was sort of my first adventure
with clinical research on Valley Fever,
and I mean these were dogs
that were failing medication,
so the next step for them was euthanasia
and those are the kind of dogs we enrolled
and we saved about 50-60% of them.
BUNTZMAN: In the weeks before I felt the pain
in my chest, 2-3 weeks is the incubation period.
I must've acquired it and breathed
it in from the air sometime
in that time frame 2-3 weeks before, and I had
been working on a grant for 2-3 weeks before
and the only places I went: home,
car, work, to work, car, home.
I actually recall being right outside here on
the little causeway, there's a little bridge
that connects the two buildings to each
other and thinking to myself, [inhales] ah,
I'm finally outside, I'm going to just
let the air hit me and breath in the air.
You don't have to be out in
the wilderness to get this.
You don't have to be digging in
the dirt in order to get this.
When spores, little fungi, are on
the wind blowing through the air,
all you have to do is merely walk into
that little pocket of wind and inhale it.
It's a very difficult thing to
answer how and where did you get it.
So the presumption is I just walked
into the wrong pocket of wind.